كم من كفيف في النظر قد فاق اصحاب البصر
بالعلم اصبح شعله يهدي البصيره
للبشر ننحاك ان تنظر لنا نظر البئيس
المنكسر فلنا عقول عزمها يقوى على نصف
[تصفيق]
الحجر لقاءكم خير مسائكم قصص وتجارب
عشناها
وتذوقنا الم الصعوبات
وتخطيناها حتى وصلنا الى ما وصلنا اليه
الان
وجدنا اليوم لنلهمكم ونلهم العالم حتى
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
معكم الطالبه نور الكنزاري طالبه جامعه
السلطان قابوس كليه الاداب العلوم
الاجتماعيه تخصص علم الاجتماع والعمل
الاجتماعي تخصص مساند سعيده جدا ان اكون
بينكم اليوم
ان شاء الله هناك ظهور تتحدث ساتحدث عنها
ان شاء الله اولا من هو الشخص الكفيف
ثانيا
ما التقنيات المساعده التي يستخدمها
الكثير اثناء دراستك
ثالثا
اين كانت نورا واين وصلت الان
اولا الشخص الكفيل
شخص حرم للنعمه البصر ولكن
عوضه الله بنور البصيره
وبثقه بالنفس وبمواهب متعدده
ايضا شخص
يعني
يتحدى الصعوبات
والعواقب ليصل الى طموحاته واحلامه
انواع الاعاقه البصريه
الشخص الكثيف كليا الفاقد للبصر بشكل فردي
والاشخاص الذين هم لديهم بقايا نظر
يستطيعون يعني يعوم ولكن بشكل يعني بسيط
بقايا بسيطه من التقنيات المساعده طبعا
تختلف لدينا العسل البيضاء العسل البيضاء
هي رمز للكفيل حاملها شخص كفيف ومن خلال
العسل البيضاء يستطيع الكفيف ان ينتقل من
مكان الى اخر دون مساعده اي شخص
جهاز البرايتنس والبود شبيهه باجهزه
اللابتوب والكمبيوتر
يقرا التكيف من خلال هذه الاجهزه ويكتب
يعني يتصفح المواقع مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
بالنسبه لي ايضا نستخدم ايضا جهاز
الكمبيوتر بشكل عادي
طبعا
البرنامج لمساحه اللي هو برنامج الامريكي
لكن الشخص اللي هو ضعيف النظر يستخدم
المكبر يستخدم المكبر لكي يعني توضح له
الصور والكلمات الى
بالنسبه
نوره اي مكان وصلت الان طبعا انا
من محافظه
كانت في المدارس العائليه يعني مع الاشخاص
العاديين
لا ما كانت المدرسه مهيئه للطالب الكفيل
ليست هناك اجهزه ولا كتب ولا اي شيء
فاعتمد على حافه السمع
واختباراتي ودراسه كانت
سمع كل شيء شفويا
اكونتي دراستي
واشارك في الانشطه المدرسيه
وخارج المدرسه على مستوى السلطنه خارج
السلطنه
حتى يعني اصبحت اواجه
الجمهور اذا كنت فيه فعاليه او احتفال
يعني بدون بدون خوف بدون قلق اطلع الجمهور
بشكل عادي جدا ولا جدا يعني مستمتعه وفعلا
والحمد لله الان اكمل دراستي في جامعه
السلطان قابوس ان شاء الله خريجه
يعني وان شاء الله يعني دعواتكم
[تصفيق]
فنكمل عن الشخص الكفيف انا رسالتي يعني
اريد ان اوسطها لكم هي اعطاء الشخص الكفيف
كامل الثقه
بالقيام
بالاعمال سواء كانت في العمل في الوظيفه
في الدراسه يعني لا تحلموا الشخص والكفيف
عن ممارسه حياتك هناك بعض الاسر صراحه
يعني تحرم
يعني للشخص الكفيف من ممارسه حياته ومن
الدراسه والعمل ليش يعني انا يعني جدا
يعني استغرب يعني صراحه
فالشخص الكبير نفسه اي شخص عادي يستطيع
بعد ذلك انت اذا اعطيت يعني الثقه الكامله
هذا الشخص سيصبح
يعني مبدع في كافه مجالات الحياه
وسيكبر ويكون اسره وتصبح الامراه ولا يصلح
يعني الرجل الاب
يعني
فاتمنى من الجميع الان وانتم تسمعونني هنا
يعني ننتظر رسالتي هذه الى
كافه المجتمع ولو برساله بسيطه تخرجون من
هنا تكتبون مثلا على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي انا يعني
كذا وكذا من هذه المعلومات عن التماثل
اليها
والرسال الاقوى اللي هي عمان
طعور
نصب عليه لكم وفي قلوبكم كما اوصاكم
السلطان الراحل قابوس ابن سعيد طيب الله
تراه وكما يصيبكم الان
جلاله السلطان هيثم مطارق اكل عمان ثم
عمان ثم عمان
عمان جميله
وتستحق منا كل جميل
فعلا
[تصفيق]
حكم الكثير وما زالت تعطي وتعطي وتعطي
فلنقدم ولو شيئا بسيط من اجله
[موسيقى]
انت
روحي
انت قلبي
فداء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عمر